hi i'm evan carmichael and today i'm
going to be sharing with you
seven ways to achieve wealth and success
these are the seven things that you need
to do to accomplish your goals to hit
your big dreams
and to build a successful business ready
here we go
number one is follow your passion you
have to follow your passion
you have to love what you do so many
entrepreneurs start a business just
trying to make money and if that's your
end goal
it's never going to work out look at the
most successful entrepreneurs at all
time look at them all
look back to how they started look back
to why they started
it was never just to make a lot of money
yes
you need to make money this is not a
charity i want you to make lots of money
but the path to money comes by following
your passion
you have to do something that you feel
here something that's making the world a
better place something that truly
helps people not just something that
you're trying to make a lot of money off
of because if that's your only goal if
money is your only goal
you're never going to make it you have
to follow your passion and do
what you love number two is figure out
what you stand for
what do you stand for who are you give
me
one word that describes who you are and
what you're all about and then express
that to the world
because if you want to have success as
an entrepreneur it's not just about
selling products and services
people want to know who you are and what
you stand for
and if people can connect to you and
feel your purpose
and know why you're doing this then
they're much more likely
to buy from you to tell their friends
about you and pay a premium
and drive further and spend more money
to work with you compared to other
people because they connect with that
purpose
so what do you stand for make it one
word make it simple
make it easy to understand and use it in
all your marketing so that people can
talk about you
number three is model success whatever
goal you have for your business
it's already been done people have
already accomplished
whatever it is that you're trying to do
you don't have to reinvent the wheel
for everything you don't have to come up
with every new idea
for your business the fastest way to
accomplish success is to model success
find people who've already done what
you're trying to do
research their strategies and apply it
to your business
to get results that you can get results
in days what may have taken somebody
else
years to do or you decades to figure out
because you have some working strategies
so model success find entrepreneurs that
you look up to who've done what you want
to do
and apply their lessons to your business
number four is don't spend until you
earn
anybody can spend money okay anybody if
i gave you a million dollars you could
find a million different ways to do it
not everybody can make money can earn
money
this is a challenge for a lot of
entrepreneurs so when you're first
starting up
don't focus on where you can spend the
money you don't need an office
you don't need business cards you don't
need a new suit you don't need a car you
don't need
any of that stuff what you need is your
hustle you need
hustle and investing from your profits
and not from your pockets okay don't go
out and spend a ton of money on
something to get it started
find a way to start small without
investing money invest your time
to make something work to start seeing
some dollars then
invest that back into your business to
grow don't spend
until you earn number five is over
deliver like crazy
the best marketing strategy that i know
is to over deliver
like crazy when you get your first
customer
go crazy servicing them give them way
more than they ever thought they would
get you know they're paying you for
x and what you want to provide is x y z
right give them way more over deliver go
way outside
the scope of what was expected from you
because
when you first get started you know when
they hire you to do whatever project or
they buy whatever product from you
you're you're one person of many that
they're working with
right you're a tiny piece of their life
or of their business
you want to make that piece bigger you
want to become more important
for example you're selling to businesses
you don't want to just be
another service provider to them you
want to be an integral part of their
business
you want them thinking i can't imagine
how we ever did this
without this person helping us you have
to be that important
so you have to start over delivering
like crazy give them so much value
that they can't imagine ever continuing
on
without you how do you provide that kind
of value because when you can do it
they're going to give you bigger budgets
they're going to give you more projects
they're going to order way more for you
they're going to refer
other people to you you got to get that
word of mouth going because you can't
afford
to go out and take out super bowl ad
commercials right
over deliver like crazy number six
is focus your efforts you have to stay
focused okay as entrepreneurs we've got
a million and one things to do in our
business we have a million one
ideas of where we could take the company
you need to stay
focused okay find the one thing that you
are one of the best people at the world
in and instead of diverting your
attention to try to cover all these
million different things
picked out one thing focus on it make it
amazing
be the best in the world at it share
your knowledge and you'll get
way better output by focusing on what
you're really good at and love doing
than if you're trying to scatter your
focus across all these different efforts
cut everything else out and stay focused
and number seven is create a supportive
environment a huge challenge for
entrepreneurs is staying motivated
listen one day you're all excited you're
going hard you've got this big dream
you've got this big goal you're going to
make it happen this is the day
you're going to land this client
whatever it is you're super pumped and
motivated and excited
and then the next day it's like you're
starting all over again and then you
don't believe in yourself and say ah
i don't think i can hit that goal and
and you know where did all my energy go
you need to create an environment
that supports you regularly where you
wake up you have a routine
that supports you that you're surrounded
with people
and books and ideas and media and in
an office space or working environment
that supports you that builds you up
that make you believe in yourself
that give you confidence to keep going
and you may be thinking well i don't
have
those kinds of friends i don't have
those people in my life right now
design it right if you have friends who
aren't supporting you
get new friends right if you need
mentors to help guide you
you don't know any super successful
billionaire entrepreneurs to
give you encouragement and motivation
read their stories
find their videos check out their
interviews right
being surrounded by these people even if
you don't know them personally
rubs off on you gets you more motivated
seeing an interview with jay-z or
richard branson or whoever it is
might spark something in you start your
day with that
watching videos like this maybe that's
the fuel that you need to get going
start your day so you have that first
thing in the morning and you're ready to
go for the rest of the day
you need to design an environment that
every day supports you
to go out and believe in yourself and
accomplish your goals
so in summary the seven ways to achieve
wealth and success number one
follow your passion number two figure
out what you stand for
number three model success number four
don't spend until you earn
number five overdiver like crazy number
six focus your efforts and number seven
create a supportive environment and
believe
for those of you watching the video you
liked it you can subscribe
to see more just like it thank you so
much i'll see you soon
and don't forget for my best information
join my newsletter and get on the
believe team
today hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to
period